[Musique]
bonjour je suis Céline en
francquichignol directrice innovation et
enseignement supérieur à l'agglomération
de 50 ans en Yvelines et je co-organise
avec Jean-Luc mélo l'événement ski
[Musique]
c'est l'événement des innovations et des
talents pour booster vos opportunités
que ce soit en termes d'emploi ou en
termes d'opportunités d'affaires qui se
tiendra dans un lieu unique le vélodrome
national les 19 et 20 avril
[Musique]
pour cet événement on a choisi de faire
un événement beaucoup plus ciblé pour
répondre aux demandes des recruteurs du
territoire et on ne sait notamment
focalisé par exemple sur le job dating
sur un public première expérience mais
qualifié à partir de bac + 2 jusqu'aux
chercheurs
n'est pas un nouvel événement c'est le
choix de réinventer des événements qui
avaient fait leurs preuves aujourd'hui
mais sur lesquelles on voulait pouvoir
apporter des innovations donc
historiquement ce qui emploie qui se
passait sur une journée dédiée à
l'emploi Vélodrome et le Skype Business
Day et donc on a voulu réunir les deux
étoffer pour vraiment booster toutes les
opportunités pour les entreprises
[Musique]
dans les focus que l'on fait sur cette
édition c'est aussi de mettre en lumière
les filières stratégiques du territoire
qui sont l'aéronautique spatiale défense
la mobilité au sens large le numérique
bien évidemment la santé l'environnement
et l'énergie qui sont voilà vraiment des
drivers pour nos entreprises et pour les
développements d'innovation sur le
territoire
[Musique]
ça se traduira sur les deux jours par la
présence d'un corner JO avec le premier
jour les opportunités
d'emploi notamment avec Pôle Emploi
l'émission locale qui vont venir
présenter les possibilités le deuxième
jour les possibilités business où là on
travaille avec la fabrique des jeux
solidaires pour mettre en exergue et
aider notamment les PME et les
entreprises de l'ESS à se saisir de
toutes les opportunités et puis bien sûr
on présentera très concrètement les JO à
50 ans en Yvelines les épreuves que nous
allons accueillir et puis comment ça
entraîne une dynamique sur le territoire
à travers des conférences et une
émission télé